[MUSIC PLAYING]
CEASAR MCDOWELL: The people
who are living in cities
represent a complexity
of the human experience
that we've never
organized around.
If you have a democracy,
and you need your public
to be able to be
engaged, you need
to have a system for doing that.
We actually don't have one
for that kind of public.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Today
on the podcast,
we're exploring the world of
civic design and re-imagining
what public engagement in
demographically complex
communities might look like.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CEASAR MCDOWELL: There
are no complete solutions.
You have to learn
how to make decisions
in the midst of ambiguity,
which means, for you internally,
you have to have your own
dialogue with yourself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: I'm your
host, Sarah Hansen.
In this episode, I'm talking
with an MIT professor
who bravely navigates
along the deepest
rifts in our public
discourse, and who
works with students and
communities alike to step
consciously into these spaces.
My guest today is
Professor Ceasar McDowell,
who teaches course 11.312,
Engaging Community.
But before we get
into our conversation,
we wanted to pause to
remember that so many
of our OCW team members,
and probably many of you,
have lost people that they
love over this past year.
And so we're dedicating this
last episode of Season 2
to all of our loved ones,
and to all of yours,
and to all of those who
carry their light forward.
Professor McDowell
approaches his work
with community engagement
like it's an art form.
In fact, he's built an
entire design framework
for practitioners to shape and
facilitate these engagements.
But before we get
into all of that,
we need to understand
the main problem
his work seeks to address,
his why, if you will.
CEASAR MCDOWELL:
Things are actually
changing in this country.
Our populations are changing.
And right now, in
cities, I think
we're just seeing that more
pronounced than anywhere else.
Right?
That the people who
are living in cities
just happen to represent a
complexity of human experience
that we've never
organized around.
And if you have a democracy,
and you need your public
to be able to be
engaged, you need
to have a system for doing that.
We actually don't have one
for that kind of public.
SARAH HANSEN: A lot of Professor
McDowell's course and work
center around the
idea of democracy.
But in this episode, when
we talk about democracy,
we're not talking about
elections and voting.
When Professor McDowell
speaks of democracy,
he's talking about the
engagement, the communities,
the conversations, the processes
that we have as a public
to come together
and make decisions.
And a lot of these processes
that we traditionally
consider democracy in action
are a little outdated.
CEASAR MCDOWELL:
I'll tell you what
I mean by we don't
have a democracy that
works for who we are.
I'll give you an example of
how we hold on to something
as a way of thinking about
democracy that does not
serve us well right now.
You can go back to the
founding of the country.
And you look at the
original colonies.
They weren't the
original colonies,
the people came and
occupied the land
and created these opportunities
for themselves here.
And if you look at those,
they created this thing
that we hold as a
myth today, which
is this thing of the New
England town meeting, town hall.
But if we're really serious
about looking at that,
there were some things that
were very true about that.
It was mostly open to men
who were property owners.
Most of these people who
were men and property owners
lived in enclaves that
shared a religious belief.
OK?
So you take that as a core, and
you then build your processes
around that core that allow
you to come to decisions.
Over time, what we've
been doing is saying,
well, we don't want
to be that exclusive.
We want to let a
few more people in.
So we modify that
a little bit more.
And over time, that's
what we've been doing.
We've been modifying it
more, modifying it more.
And then you get to something
like the presidential debates.
And what do we have?
What do we say is the
way we let the public
into this conversation?
These televised town halls, they
have no reality or connection
to the complexity of who we are.
But we hold on to
them as our evidence
that we are doing and engaging
the public around a dialogue.
So this is what I mean
is we don't have it.
We actually don't have a
functioning infrastructure
for democracy, given the
complexity of who we are.
So that's what I mean by that.
It's not just about voting.
It's the infrastructure
that allows
people to do the work that
the public has to do in order
for democracy to function.
SARAH HANSEN: The
new infrastructure
Professor McDowell
is talking about
here involves a shift away
from the more traditional forms
of civic engagement
and participation.
Professor McDowell's
way involves
looking at a given situation
from multiple perspectives,
and then spending time to
reflect on our own values
and the needs of our community.
CEASAR MCDOWELL: At
one point in my life,
I lived in Alaska way up
above the Arctic Circle.
I was associate superintendent
of a new school system there
that was the size of
the State of Indiana.
It had 100 villages,
5,000 people, no roads.
OK?
So that's the context,
predominantly Inupiat.
And there was this one
instance in the village where
we had a teacher who was
actually not performing
very well in the school.
And we were really concerned.
The principal was concerned.
We were concerned.
And the teacher was Anglo in
this predominantly Inupiat
village.
And we had decided to remove
the teacher, because this
was the best thing for the kids,
just wasn't performing well.
And there was a
meeting in the village,
where we talked about that.
And there was a
lot of resistance.
And so the
superintendent asked me
to go and try to find
out what's going on.
And so I went, in these little
villages you could do it.
I talked to almost everyone.
[LAUGHS]
I talked to a lot of
people in the village.
And here's what was happening.
The school was saying, this
person is not a good teacher.
And people were saying, this
person is a good teacher.
And we couldn't reconcile.
But what we learned, when we
started to talk to people,
is that we were evaluating the
teacher in very different ways.
Inside the school, the
good was really applied--
For the school
system, the good was
applied to how well
is this person taking
care of the educational
needs of the children.
For some of the people in the
community, teacher was a role.
Good was the value
to the community.
She was good for the community
because of other functions
she played in the community.
And so we had this totally
different use of language.
And they knew that if she
wasn't there as a teacher,
she wouldn't be there.
Because she'd have to leave.
And so other values to the
community would be lost.
That kind of perspective
taking, I think, is so required.
And as we find ways to
bring people together,
we have to start to
construct mechanisms
that allow people to do
that kind of reflection
and that kind of perspective
taking in relationship
to the other.
SARAH HANSEN: One of the
challenges of getting people
to practice tuning into
different perspectives
is a physical one.
In our current
political climate,
how do we even get people
with different perspectives
in the same room?
CEASAR MCDOWELL: So
we start this campaign
where we're testing out now.
It's called America's
Path Forward.
In the campaign, we're
actually reaching out
to people in the public.
And we're asking them to do one
thing, actually, two things.
One is to donate
the question they
have about the future of
America and the experience
of their life that led
them to their question.
And then what we do
is we bring people
who have similar questions,
and sometimes not,
into small conversations.
In those conversations,
all people
are doing is sharing a question,
sharing their experience.
And what people
find is, one, when
they go into these
rooms with people
who have similar
questions, they're
surprised at who's in the room.
Because the thing that
they hold as what's theirs,
they're realizing that's
a different set of people
who actually hold this too.
And then when they have
different experiences,
they're beginning
to realize, oh,
this question manifests itself
in totally different ways.
Right?
It's the same question,
but it's living out
differently in our society.
And for me, this
is a way of helping
the public build its own kind
of reflection and connection
to others.
And what we try to
get people to do
at the end of
these conversations
is to say, if you could
reframe this question so
that if it was addressed,
it would more likely attend
to the different ways
you are experiencing,
how would you
reframe the question?
Just getting people to
start and think that way,
holding the public as
curious intellectual beings,
and encouraging them in that,
to say, yes, this is hard work.
And yes, you can do it.
SARAH HANSEN: Professor
McDowell has worked with a team
to create a tool for having
better public conversations.
The tool is called the
Civic Design Framework.
I was curious about
how the design
element fits into this kind
of community engagement work.
CEASAR MCDOWELL: Yeah.
So when I think about community
engagement and design,
the reason I put
those two together
is to talk about the
purposefulness of how we go out
in the world and create
engagement processes.
And that they actually are
designed and can be designed.
The main thing I'm trying to get
people to pay attention to is,
when you're putting together
an engagement process,
you have the ability
to construct it
for certain kinds of
outcomes and processes
that you want to have happen
and the connections you
want to have happen.
And therefore, that's
a design challenge.
Given the population you
work with and the issue
you're going out
to the public with,
how then do you construct that?
The sets of things that can
happen, so that they actually
allow you to bring people, not
just closer together, but also,
what I like to say is
help people, the public,
build its muscle for democracy.
SARAH HANSEN: The Civic Design
Framework gives us a way
into these conversations
that are central to having
a truly functional democracy.
Professor McDowell
teaches the framework
to students in 11.312,
Engaging Community.
CEASAR MCDOWELL: We, really,
use the Civic Design Framework
as a tool for organizing
thinking and projects.
And the framework really
has two components to it.
It's based on the
notion that part
of the issue of
bringing the public
into any engagement
process is we're not
clear about what conversation
we're inviting them into.
Our problem with our public
discourse and engagement
process is we often invite
people into one conversation.
And then when they
get in the room,
we set them up for another.
So we will say to them,
tell them, imagine
a new Sarasota, Florida.
And you go into the room, and
you have three choices to make.
So basically, you've
set people up.
And no wonder people
are really dissatisfied.
The other thing why
it's important to know
which kind of
conversation you have,
is that they each require
something different.
If you want to be in a framing
conversation with someone,
that's totally different.
You're using really different
cognitive structures
than if you're in
the ideation process.
Because in the ideation
process, you're
trying to ignite imagination.
In a framing
conversation, you're
really trying to
deeply understand
experience and what's
happening in the world.
So those are very different.
And so if you don't know
what kind of conversation
you want to have
in public, you're
not going to design
it the right way.
SARAH HANSEN: What's
really exciting
about Professor
McDowell's class is
that he doesn't just teach the
theory of this Civic Design
Framework.
Students are also invited to
bring forward actual cases
from the communities with
which they're already
engaging, where they
can implement the design
framework in real life.
CEASAR MCDOWELL: I
always try to generate
this opportunity
for students to say,
here are the things
we want to work on.
And then to negotiate among
themselves which ones they
really want to move forward on.
We did one in Mexico, and that
one, it's actually interesting.
It was a former alum
of our department
who had just stepped into this
major role in a new government
in a town in Mexico.
And they had got there through
a popular, all grassroot
campaign.
And now they wanted
to figure out,
how do we carry that
into a structure,
into governance,
that actually allows
to keep the public involved?
And so the class was
really helping them
through that design.
So it's always that some
problem, some place,
where people are trying
to figure out how we broad
and diversify how they're
engaging with the public.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: One of the
realities of collaborating
with real people
in real communities
is that practitioners
often find themselves
in situations where
solutions are complicated
and, sometimes, not complete.
Professor McDowell offered
some important words of wisdom
for practitioners
new to field work.
CEASAR MCDOWELL: I think
it's not just this course,
but in any real
practice-based course,
that puts you out
into the field.
There are a couple of things
that you have to contend with.
One, there are no
complete solutions.
You have to learn
how to make decisions
in the midst of ambiguity.
You just, you have
to do it, which
means, for you
internally, you have
to have your own
dialogue with yourself
to understand how you're
holding onto the things
that you believe.
Even if you're not able
to really achieve them,
within the midst of any one
project or any one initiative,
but you're still not
letting it get to you.
And one of the ways
we talk about this
is I make a real
distinction in our class
around how we talk about things.
So for example, in
our society, we're
really good at
what I would say is
this kind of language of
evaluation, how well something
is or not.
And we're also good at
language of critique which
is different than evaluation.
And we're really good at
this language of possibility.
We're looking into the future.
What we're not really
good at is talking
about the reality, what I call
the language of transition.
And the reality is we
have things we want to do.
And as we're trying to do
those things to change systems
we want to be different, we
have to support the systems
that we're trying to change.
And so we live in
this in-between space,
this space called Nepantla.
That's where we live.
And in that space,
we have to learn
how to talk to each other.
And this is why I
always use these terms
like grace and stuff like that.
Because of the recognition
that that's where you are.
So in my class, I
try to support folks
of being able to talk about
that, about what they're living
with in the middle,
what they're having
to hold onto that they don't
necessarily feel good about.
But they know they have
to do it as they're
trying to do this other thing.
And to support them through
that kind of conversation.
This is a reflection
of the transition
you're living in, and just
a recognition of that,
and honoring it, and
letting it be OK.
It's almost being able to
have a dialogue of forgiveness
with yourself.
SARAH HANSEN: I wanted to know
what these engagements look
like in practice.
So Professor McDowell
shared with me
one example that took place in
my very own city of Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
The dialogue was around
domestic violence
and how the city could
better address the issue.
And the engagement was simple.
Professor McDowell and his team
asked residents of Cambridge
to donate a question they
had about domestic violence.
CEASAR MCDOWELL: Think
about domestic violence.
That is not a
public conversation.
That's not a thing
that people talk about.
Because we have a
structure of all
you have to do is
donate a question,
a group of young people from
Cambridge Rindge and Latin
set up a booth at
Harvard Square.
They put up a board,
and they made cookies.
And they just basically had
a cookie for your question.
And people would
write their question
about domestic violence and put
it on board and get a cookie.
And then people start
having conversations
in public about what's on the
board and what they're hearing.
So you're taking something
that we don't talk about
and moving forward.
At the same time,
what we did is we
took all the questions
that came in,
printed them out very large.
And we had a space in
Cambridge that we could use,
where we put all 2,000-something
questions up on the wall.
And we created a
public event where
people would come in,
read the questions,
and sit down to
have conversations
with each other about what
they were seeing and hearing.
And then we had
people from the public
come in and say,
let's figure out,
can we organize these
questions in certain kinds
of themes and issues?
And then we had
conversation with people
about themes and issues.
So all of this is taking
something we don't talk about
and creating an opportunity
for people to do it.
Because you're, in some sense,
recognizing that everyone
has something to say about this.
But if you do it
in the right way,
you don't try to tell them
what they have to say,
or how they have
to say it, you just
create an opportunity
that equalizes voices.
People step up.
SARAH HANSEN: This idea about
equalizing voices and bringing
everyone to the
table is incredibly
important in Professor
McDowell's work.
One specific aspect of
his design framework
speaks directly to this idea.
It's built on the
notion of equity.
And it's a concept he calls
designing for the margins.
CEASAR MCDOWELL:
The reason I use
this concept of
design for the margins
is our default in
everything we do in design
is designed for the middle,
where most people are.
And we do that because
we want to scale.
We want things to grow fast.
We want to make sure we're
taking care of a lot of people.
But the thing about
when you design
for those that
are in the middle,
you're mostly
designing for people
who, more or less, can operate
within systems that are there.
And then what that ends up
doing is pushing people margins
further and further out.
And as other things
in our systems fail,
we end up putting more and
more people into that margin.
And by the margins,
I mean those who
are living with the
failures of the society.
And so if we're going
to attend to that,
and actually bring
their voices in,
we have to first design
opportunities and engagement
processes that work
for them first.
Because those in the middle
will find their way into that.
Because they have the
resources, the opportunity.
They know how to
negotiate the system.
The other thing when you
design for the margins you do
is, because they're
clearly living
with the failures
of the systems,
you're able to design around
the things that would normally
keep people out.
So it's a purposeful thing that
actually benefits more people.
If you actually do that--
and we have instances
of that in everyday life that
shows that, some physical ones,
like the curb cut.
The curb cut was a
thing that came up,
very particular movement from
the disabilities community
decades ago to
create some access,
and a lot of fights
to get it done,
but the interesting
thing about is
is you look at it now and say,
well, who benefits from that?
That's a design for a very
small population of the country.
Who benefits from it?
Who uses it?
Well, everybody that rides
a bicycle, pushes a trailer,
carries a grocery cart.
SARAH HANSEN: Stroller.
CEASAR MCDOWELL: Right?
Strollers, it's
all there, right?
But that's not what
it was designed for.
It was designed for
the margin, but yet,
all these central activities
that people are involved in
and what I would
call the middle,
are able to benefit
from that too.
The interesting thing about
it, and why I actually
like to use an example,
is what have you
noticed about changes in
curb cuts in the last decade?
They have bumps on them now.
They have texture to them.
And they have texture to
them, because it helps people
without sight to know if
they're coming to a corner.
So the thing about
designing for the margins,
it's not the thing
you've achieve.
It's a thing that you're
always working at.
Because the margins
will keep emerging.
SARAH HANSEN: If you're
anything like me,
you may be thinking to
yourself that this is exactly
the kind of work
that our country
and, really, our planet
could use more of, better,
more open, more connected ways
to engage groups of people
around complex issues, and
a design framework that
allows us to keep
working at those issues.
Part of what I love about
Professor McDowell's work
is that it's grounded in doing
the hard work of community
in community together.
CEASAR MCDOWELL: The way
that our systems are set up
right now, they really are
designed to keep people apart,
to disconnect people
from each other,
or groups from each other.
And they draw these
false dichotomies.
But in reality, people live
with a much more complex set
of things.
So for example, you take the
movement for Black lives.
And you take the way that,
in a very powerful way, using
the notions of defund the
police, and [? some other ?]
views, and others to
change what policing is.
Because they have seen that
evidence over and over again
of the devaluing of Black lives
within the midst of the police.
However, even with that same
experience, knowledge base,
you can go into the
Black community,
and people have very
different feelings
about do we defund
the police or not?
The trading off of their
I know there's a risk,
but that risk is in
here, and it's out there,
and I don't know
how to balance it.
I don't know what
to do about that.
When we put things
in an either or, then
we really lose the opportunity
to really connect people,
to create some
opportunity for people
to acknowledge what's
the complexity out there.
And how do you go through
that in a way that
doesn't leave people behind?
Or leave them to the
side, I should say.
You can use policing as some.
You could use what's happening
with vaccinations as another.
There's a lot of things
that are just structured.
And the way we talk
about them in the public
doesn't recognize one thing
that we know is really true.
Our values kind of
lie on a continuum.
And what we're always doing is
trading off one for the other.
We're going back and forth.
People looking at
things, and they're
looking at that value
versus another value,
versus another value.
And why that's important
for public conversations
is, if we can step away from
saying, your value's this
and mine is that, and
you can get people
in the space to realize, oh,
this is how you're trading off
this set of values.
And this is how I'm
trading them off.
Then what you realize is
that people are holding
--have within them--
the same values.
They really are just shifting
and weighing them differently
at different times.
And that creates more of
an opportunity for people,
at least, to see the other.
They may not agree.
But they begin to see the other.
And that's, in our society,
where so many groups of people
have been so dehumanized,
our first step
is to let people be seen.
SARAH HANSEN: Through
all the social upheaval
and the many defining
events of 2020,
Professor McDowell has continued
to spend a lot of his time
engaging with students.
He often works with
smaller class sizes.
So that he can develop
the close relationships
he feels are essential.
This kind of close
contact allows
him to see into students'
lives beyond the classroom.
And he shared with me some
insights into what he's seeing
and what educators
can do to help.
CEASAR MCDOWELL: I think
students are dealing with a lot
right now.
And it's not just
because of COVID.
I think our society is
in a huge transition.
I can't tell you
how many students
I have right now who don't feel
connected to their families
anymore because of what's
going on politically
in this country, that disruption
that people are sitting with.
And so then you ask,
how do we, as educators,
knowing they're
sitting with this,
help them to
actually move forward
in a way that is
going to allow them
to be generative with other
people in the communities they
work with and also
find their own path?
And so for me, teaching always
has to be grounded in reality.
You have to be working with
others who are actually
dealing with the
problem, or the issue,
or who want to do
something, and you just
have to work with them.
And it really is about lifting
up and supporting people
through that process
of working with others
and working with yourself.
In some ways, a
lot of my teaching
is, yes, it's about
substantive issues.
But it is also about helping
people develop, not only
just a theory or practice,
but a reflective strategy
for themselves as they
move through their careers
and through their lives.
SARAH HANSEN: There's a lot
of excitement about Professor
McDowell's work and teaching.
So we had some really
wonderful listener questions
sent in for this episode.
And we're excited to share
two of them with you now.
Here's one a listener sent in.
For people who are used to
having privileged access
to policy discussion and
implementation spaces,
what habits should
we watch out for?
Are there subconscious
attitudes or behaviors
that get in the way of including
historically excluded people?
CEASAR MCDOWELL: That's a
really beautiful question.
I think the number
one habit we have
to watch out for is a
habit that we actually
understand the issue.
That we fully understand it.
We have to make space
for people to be
able to reframe the
issues with understanding.
If we hold onto our
frame, from that position,
we will never really fully
be able to include others.
So for me, that's
the critical issue.
And that means we have to
make time and space for that.
And that pushes
against so much of what
we who are in these
these policy areas
think about is because
we try to do everything.
We've got to do everything.
We got to do it, and
we've got to get it right.
And I think the mantra should
be we're going to do something.
We're not going to
get it quite right.
You can take some time
to maybe understand
it a little different.
We're going to do
something then.
We're not going to
get it quite right.
We're going to take time to
understand it differently.
It's like-- because
that's the reality.
It is the reality.
So we have to acknowledge it.
SARAH HANSEN: And to close,
one more listener question,
one that very well may have been
on your mind while listening.
Is it easier or harder to
have difficult conversations
in small groups or large
town hall settings?
How do we scale up dialogues?
How do you adjust the
questions, the tone, the pacing
to accommodate large
and diverse audiences?
CEASAR MCDOWELL:
I'm a firm believer
in small scale dialogues to deal
with really difficult issues.
If we try to do it in a large
scale audience, we, one,
you can't have everyone's
voice in there,
which means you're inevitably
silencing certain people.
And I'm not saying don't
do large-scale events,
because it's good sometimes
just to sit in a place
and listen, and hear,
and watch others.
That has value.
But the transformational
piece [? everyone is, ?] I
think is being in small
space dialogues with others.
I think we need work at
turning our technologies
and designing our communication
systems to support that kind
of listening and conversation.
And that's not what we have.
They're driven by other things.
That's one of the
problems with them.
So I think we can
get there if we
shift our intention, our
design intention, to that.
And the reality of it
is all of our incentives
for creating things like that
are in the opposite direction.
[LAUGHS]
It's like, it's really
hard to build technologies
that are designed
for the margins that
are going to actually scale.
Because you have all these
other things going on.
It's a challenge.
I don't think it's a
challenge that can't be met.
SARAH HANSEN: If you're
interested in learning more
about Professor
Ceasar McDowell's work
or teaching with his open
educational resources,
you can check out
his course 11:312,
Engaging Community on our
MIT OpenCourseWare website.
You can also listen to his
podcast, We Who Engage.
It's available wherever
you listen to podcasts.
Thanks for tuning in for our
second season of Chalk Radio.
We hope you enjoyed
these episodes
and will consider sharing this
or any of our other episodes
with a friend, family
member, or colleague.
We have more in
store for Season 3
and are already working hard
to bring you more episodes
to inspire your teaching and
learning when Chalk Radio
returns in the fall.
Signing off from
Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm Sarah Hansen from
MIT OpenCourseWare.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[AUDIO BUMPER] Ma, park the car.